I'm not even a vaccine I just want to
know what the [ __ ] going on I just
want to be I just want to hand the world
over to Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates and
all of these trillionaires
billionaires soon-to-be trillionaire as
let them do whatever they want you see
this new thing on Facebook all these
boomers are sharing it and they're like
how did Bill Gates who's the best man
that ever lived who save more lives
he saves lives of the Congo he save
lives for polio how did Bill Gates be
turned into some villain at least I love
Bill Gates I don't care that he wants to
shoot a missile full of dust at the Sun
and block out the Sun who cares it's I
hate the Sun my since I thought I'd a
melanoma last week it turned out it was
it it was just a pile of dirt that
collected on my body and I didn't watch
it but I thought it was cancer I hate
the thought I don't care that Bill Gates
Watts the tunnel to the Center of the
Arts and bring back the dinosaurs he's a
good boy he's the local boy - done good
he's just all he does is try to help
people every day after the government
monopolized think they busted him on all
these Monopoly things he went into
philanthropy and decide he didn't want
to he wants to give his money away to
his charity organizations to give - you
know schools that where his son goes but
and and you know dodge taxes all over
the world by bite a bite you know by
playing [ __ ] come here with the
needle and [ __ ] whatever third-world
country won't kick him out I like Bill
and I don't want to hear anything
negative said about him not at all it
doesn't matter that he wants to send
nuclear weapons to Mars and blow it out
just for fun he understands global
warming comes from the Sun get rid of
the [ __ ] Sun get that article get
Bill Gates wants to shoot dusted - Sun
by the way this is what happens when you
let people get billions of trillions of
dollars and then nobody's you know
that's all he just wants to shoot some
dust at the Sun here we go what could go
wrong could dimming the Sun save the
earth
gates wants to spray millions of tons of
dust into the stratosphere to stop
global warming but critics fear it could
trigger calamity [ __ ] these critics
how dare who are these critics
astronomers scientists who are these
have they not heard of Windows who are
these critics stopping him from shooting
dust into the [ __ ] into the
atmosphere
who's saying it's not a good idea to
block out the Sun why not let him
experiment it's fun why are all these
conspiracy theorists what's their
problem he doesn't want the Sun anymore
he wants to dim the Sun this is not a
crackpot plan of a garden shed inventor
the project is being funded by
billionaire and Microsoft founder Bill
Gates and pioneer by scientists at
Harvard
Epstein University keep going down here
come go out for a minute go out from it
in theory the airborne touch would
create a gigantic Sun Shade reflecting
some of the sun's rays and heat back
into space dimming those that get
through so protecting Earth from the
worsening ravages of climate warming
keep going down here the initial three
million dollar test known as the
stratospheric controlled Petra bation
experiment would use a high-altitude
scientific balloon to raise around two
kilograms of calcium carbonate dust the
size of a bag of flour into the
atmosphere 12 miles above the desert of
New Mexico
this would seed a tube shaped area of
the sky about half a mile long a hundred
yards in diameter for the ensuing 24
hours a balloon would be steered by
propellers back through the artificial
cloud its onboard sensors monitoring
this dust Sun reflecting abilities and
its effect on the thin surrounding air
okay
however scope acts on is on hold this
wasn't calling it I guess scope X is on
hold amid fears it could trigger a
disastrous series of chain reactions
creating climate havoc in the form of
serious droughts and hurricanes and
bring death to millions of people around
the world
I don't want a bad word about barrel how
did a man who just wants to cure disease
and get rid of the Sun get a bad rap on
Facebook
all these Yahoo's are making fun of
William I love Bill so what he wants
Americans to live underground so that
the ravages of global warming don't stop
them he wants to create a slave of a
slave race of Lycans who has white skin
because they're all albinos they can
live underground it's nice under grabs
you ever been underground it's lovely
stop it stop telling Bill what to do
he's got billions of dollars let him do
what he wants that's what they go let
him do what they want
hey let him do they want half Jeff Bezos
wants to automate and just destroy
grocery stores and everybody just could
have drone if Apple's dropped off just
let him do it let him do it doesn't
matter it's a millions of people are
gonna lose their jobs who cares
doesn't matter let him let it if they
can design a robot let him do it doesn't
matter doesn't matter doesn't really
matter we'll just let them do whatever
they want we don't want to debate the
pace of which people's jobs are going to
evaporate and be taken over by AI let
him do it's get it one of the Harvard
teams directors Lizzie burns admits our
idea is terrifying but so is climate
change
so is climate change so I want to here
pill I don't want to hear bad word about
Bill I can't believe you ninnies would
say anything so he knows he's up to no
good by the way if you ever see his
Facebook gates by the way he knows kind
of up to no good yes he wants to save
people's lives kind of but let's get
real here there's some other things
percolating and that old dome of his
there's a lot of good with the bad I'm
sure Jeffrey Epstein was nice to
waitresses maybe I don't know what if we
found that I've seen was a big tipper
and he never complained and he never
sent his food back you know I see a
Coulter note and Hitler didn't smoke
like everybody's got a thing that's nice
about them and I'm it's nice that Bill
Gates wants to cure infectious diseases
and then somehow that will also bring
the population of the planet down there
he wants to do that I get it there's too
many people I'm in LA there's too much
traffic I get it I'm with him but if you
look in his eyes in his dome he's got
some other
going on let me tell you bugging thank
God I don't have a billion dollars thank
God I don't have a billion dollars
I'd be [ __ ] I mean I wish I were him
right now I would be [ __ ] I would be
doing some much wildest [ __ ] than he is
you just got to watch him you got to
watch Bezos you got to watch these
people we know that the government is an
app the government and private industry
have gotten in bed together and they've
created what were people like Chris
Hedges have called the corporate state
which means it has all the power of the
state and all the and and and the
endless financial resources and also all
the like you know supposed credibility
of the private sector where we bring in
these geniuses incredibly intelligent we
all know like you're Bill Gates is not a
dumb guy Bezos and all these guys are
incredibly intelligent people so we
bring them in and then because we all
know people working the government kind
of dunces we all think the government's
you know up until recently when
everybody showed with Obama and Trump
and everyone's like these are gods Obama
obviously smart guy and Trump is
intelligent in his own way but the
reality is we know these geniuses exist
for the most part outside of the
government they exist making billions of
truth [ __ ] wants to work for the
government when you got heads like these
guys have they want to truly
revolutionize the world great but when
they team up with the government they're
just this unstoppable force nothing can
stop them truly nothing don't like what
you're right they delete it you don't
exist your own person doesn't matter
you're getting this health policy
whether you like it or not these are the
required things you don't like
surveillance will [ __ ] you you don't
like your email read what's getting read
FBI can go into your search history now
it doesn't matter FBI go right in your
search history
what do you search you for you search if
it's something they don't like okay
the FBI's like we are we are looking at
all of the searches and we don't mind
any we will be but we don't mind anyone
searching for child porn as long as they
make a certain amount of money and
they're searching through our approved
partners but we dude we don't really
love if
if you're on some anti-government forum
we don't love that don't propagate any
conspiracy theories don't say anything
mean about Bill's plan to block the Sun
out keep your mouth shut about that
just put a bag over your head and go to
your local Italian restaurant and get
wiped down with hand sanitizer before
you eat and let bill and the boys do
their work let bill and the boys do
their work